in this course jim will help you improve
your python skills by teaching you how
to build a mindsweeper game
jim has created many popular courses on
our channel and is an excellent teacher
so you just started to learn python and
you'll want to develop a cool project
after learning the basics well this
series of videos is exactly for you
because in this series of videos we are
going to develop a game with python now
if you know the basics and you took some
basic course no matter what channel or
what course it is then this is the
series that you are looking for because
it will give you the basics of how to
start structuring a python project now
in this series we will develop a game
that is called minesweeper which is
known as a single player game that is
very fun to play and also challenging
let's see what game you will learn to
develop in that series alright so that's
going to be the game that we will be
developing throughout this series now
you can see that we have some amount of
sales that we can go click and open them
now the main goal in mind sweeper is to
not click on a cell that has a mine
behind the cell so what that means it
means that if i was to go and open it
then you can see i receive a number back
now this means that in the surrounded
cells of that cell there is one mind
that i should not click on so i'm gonna
guess and say that you don't have a mind
here and you also don't have a mind
there and you can see that i'm quite
right so i'm going to click with my
right click of the mouse to mark it as a
mine because if i was to click that with
my left mouse click then i will lose the
game right so what i'm going to do now
is to try to guess rest of the locations
that are mindless locations right so i'm
going to click there and you can see
that i receive some numbers you can see
that for example
around the cell i have zero mine so it
is safe to click here here and as well
as there and now let's try to left click
on that location and you can see that it
says you clicked on a mine and i lost a
game and the main goal is really to
guess all the locations that are not
having in mind and then you will win the
game so that's going to be a lot of
thinking that we have to do here in
order to develop that game and it's
going to be cool dealing with all the
challenges that this game brings with it
so before we get started i'd appreciate
if you can click on a like button on
that video it will help to spread the
video to the entire youtube and also if
you know people that are just started to
learn python and they want to develop a
cool project then welcome them to watch
my series as well it could be very
helpful for those videos that are just
in the level of between getting started
and to being an expert so with that
being said let's get started now before
we get into writing this project i would
expect to you to have python installed
on your computer and as well as an ide
that is ready to go with and it
recognizes the python interpreter on
your computer i'm going to use python
3.8 but as long as you have a version
that is above that version then you
should be fine writing this project now
we are not going to use too much
external libraries or too much code that
is dependent on the version of the
python so that's okay if you even use
python 3.10 or python 3.11 that will
upcoming the future probably all right
so let's go ahead and get started now
for writing a bold game a 2d game then
we can use a lot of libraries that are
available in python in this one we are
going to use tk inter which is very nice
and a great library to practice because
it comes with a lot of useful classes
that we are going to
instantiate to create our window so
we're going to start by importing this
in the following way so i will say front
kinter import everything and that will
be a great starter for us so the next
line that i'm going to write here is to
instantiate a window instance and we
probably want to do that because our
project is going to be in a window and
i'm going to name my variable root and
this one is going to be equal to an
instantiation of that keyword tk and
that's just the most basic element that
you can create this is just a regular
window now when we will run this then
nothing is going to happen because we
need to tell to that tk that it should
run until we close it with the x button
on the top right so that will be by
saying root dot main loop like that
right so we need to call that method and
all the code is going to be between
those two lines so if we were to run
that and you can see that we have the
most basic window that is possible now
just a quick side note the reason that i
used the root variable is just a
convention in tk inter projects so it
will be easier for you to look up for
problems in stack overflow for example
if you follow those conventions alright
so let's go ahead and see some of the
attributes that we can change here to
make our window nicer so the first one
is going to be obviously to change the
size of the window and we can do that by
calling the geometry function i mean
method of this root and this accepts a
string that is looking like the
following weight
x the height and here obviously you can
put any numbers you like to now pay
attention what will happen if i was to
replace those with actual
numbers like the following then you will
see the difference immediately and if i
was to run that then you can see how it
changes now we can also pay attention
that it uses this string as the title of
our window we can change that by calling
a method that is called title and give
it any title that we like to so we can
go with a minesweeper game and
re-execute our program and you can see
the changes now i did not talk about
this but by default all the windows are
resizable and that might be something
annoying when you create a lot of
elements inside this window like buttons
or frames so that's why we probably look
to avoid resizing this window because it
will just give us an easier life when we
go ahead and put some more elements in
that window so the way that this is
achievable is by calling the resizable
method like that and basically specify
that we are not allowed to resize the
width and the height of this window and
that is achievable by
basically passing in falls twice
one for the weight and the other one for
the height
now if i was to again rerun our program
then you can see the effect of that you
can see that this maximize here is
disabled and that's just something that
going to make us an easier life in the
future when we develop this game now
after we reach that stage then we might
also be curious about how to change the
background color of our window now you
could go ahead and use hexadecimal
values if you know how to use them but
basically kinder supports a lot of
keywords for specifying the colors now
we don't want to too much deal with
styling we pretty much want to focus on
the logic in the algorithm of how to
write such a game so for that purpose
i'm going to keep it simple but still we
want to obviously have a nice visualized
window in here so i'm going to go to
that fifth line and i'm going to say
root.configure and we're going to need
to configure the background color for
our
window so we need to go ahead and call
this method and we need to pass in bg
equals to whatever color we like to
now in the description you can find a
list of colors that are available by
using keyword colors so in the
description there is a link with a large
list of colors that are available i'm
just going to use black for this window
and that will be it so you can see the
immediate effect of changing the
background color alright so now that we
understood this then let's go ahead and
see how we can create some elements
inside our window now we are going to
start with the most basic element that
you can create in a window which is
called a frame now frame is just like a
container that could contain more
elements that we will create in the
future
now we want to use those frames because
obviously we want to divide our window
into some sections so it will be easier
to understand where we want to locate
each of our buttons or texts in the
future
for example we could dedicate that area
of our window for a title right so we
will have the title over here and we
could decide that we'd like to have a
left sidebar so we could dedicate the
left area of our window into being the
sidebar to display the score for example
something like that and we could have
another frame right here so we could
display the game here so it is just a
great idea to divide the window into
multiple frames it's going to be just
helpful to visualize different elements
later on so what i'm going to do now is
writing here a comment that will say
override
the settings of
the window
and right before the root dot main loop
i am also going to comment out run the
window
and then here is the exact location that
we will start creating some frames so
let's go ahead and get started so we
said that we'd like to have a frame that
is located on the top so i will name
this variable
top frame and that will be equal to a
class that is named frame and once we
will instantiate from this frame class
then it will be responsible to
instantiate a frame which we will decide
later on where we like to locate it on
our window now the first argument that
this frame must receive is what is the
element that we'd like to locate the
frame in so it is going to be located in
the window so we will pass in root and
then i'm going to separate those into
multiple lines so it will be easier to
read and as you can see the parentheses
are open here close in here now let's go
ahead and give it more attributes so
first things first we'd like to give a
different background so we can really
differentiate between the frame and the
window because it is going to be hard to
understand where the frame is located if
we keep the same color so just for
debugging reasons
i'm keeping this red change later to
black and we'll comment that here and
then down here i will decide the width
and the height so i will say that the
width should be equal to the exact
same
width size we gave to the window because
we'd like to cover the entire window so
this should be the entire width like the
window and the height should be probably
um
180 like that so it is just 720 divided
to 4 and that makes totally sense and
now that we got this then we need to
decide where we'd like to start this
frame from so in order to do this then
i'm going to go ahead and say top
underscore frame
dot place now this place will receive
two arguments that are mandatory and
before i go ahead and pass those let me
show you how the place method works in
the window here so when we use the place
method then it needs to receive the
pixel's value now we know that we have a
frame that we like to start exactly
from here
and we know that it should probably
cover this area right but how we are
going to tell it to start it from here
well in place we need to specify the
axis x and axis y meaning that if we
want to start from the top left then we
need to give it the values of zero
point zero because that is where
everything starts in terms of pixels now
the entire area here is one thousand
four hundred 440
because that is the axis x and the axis
y
is
720 pixels so the entire height here is
720
now if for example we would want to have
a button just for example i'm not going
to do that that time but let's say that
we'd like to have a button that we
wanted it to start
here so we wanted to place it in the
middle of our page right so we need to
take that value and divide it with two
so the axis x
is 720
and we know that we would like to have
it in the top position as much as
possible so
this should be
the value of axis y which will be zero
so that's how the place method works we
need to specify the pixel value for axis
x and axis y and let me clean everything
that i draw here and go back to pycharm
and give here the values of x equals to
zero and y equals to zero and now check
out how this frame will be visualized if
i stop and rerun then you can see that
this is the expected result just like we
wanted it started from here and took the
entire area of weight and it took 180
pixels from the height so that's exactly
what we wanted now just for really
making sure that you understood this i'm
going to change this to x to 20 and you
will guess what will happen so if we
were to rerun that then obviously it
will start from a little bit left
positional you can see where it is
located right it starts just in here and
if we were to jump the y by 20 and stop
and rerun this then you can see the
result so this is how the place method
works obviously i'm going to change
those back to 0 and continue from here
all right so now that we understood that
then let's go ahead and try to create
one more frame now this time i want to
make a frame that we will use as a left
sidebar where we will display maybe the
score or something else that is useful
so i'm going to go ahead and create a
left frame variable and that's going to
be equal to the frame so we'll
instantiate one more from that class and
we want this frame in the
root and then we will say something like
bg equals to another color i will just
copy that line and paste this in and
let's use something like blue so we can
separate between different frames and
the width will be
um
360. i'm intentionally using the
value that is just quarter of that value
so it will be easier for me to
understand how much percentage of the
entire width i covered with my frames
now that i specified the weight i'm
going to specify the height so i'm going
to say that this should cover the entire
height of our window now pay attention
that we already covered 180 pixels for
the top frame so we cannot just say 780
i mean 720 like that we need to go ahead
and
remember our height size of the entire
window and subtract this number by that
number right so we should be passing
here
540. now don't worry if you think that
we hard code too much values i'm going
to make sure that we don't really have
any hardcoded values later on when we
will be restructuring this project in
the future so now we are focusing on
understanding how tkinter works so now
that we understood that then let's go
ahead and say that left frame
should be placed in x equals to 0
but the y should be equal to
180 right because we want to start it
right after
where the top frame is located and if i
was to
run our program then you can see that we
have the perfect result just to really
understand that again
if we were to take that y axis and jump
that by 20 then you can see that it
starts right from here because it jumped
20 pixels in the y axis so that's why i
want to make sure that we keep the value
of 180 right so now that we have reached
that stage you can notice probably that
we are going to have too much hard-coded
numbers in terms of using the weight and
the height and the pixels etc so that's
a great time having a separated file for
all of our constants and have at least
some variables stored in somewhere now
i'm not going to make that in our
main.py file because that might be too
much information that needs to be stored
in one file besides i'm going to grab in
a new python file and i'm going to call
that settings so inside here i can use
some constants that will be helpful and
to really show you those windows side by
side let me use the right click and
split vertically option so we can start
thinking about some good candidates for
variables that we'd like to store here
for example we can start with the width
size of our window we can say that
weight
is equal to 1440
we can say that the height is equal to
720
and we can immediately go back to our
main.py file and say something like
import settings
and then we could go here and use a
formatted string
and we could just convert those into
that string right we can say here
settings
dot wait
and
we can go with settings
dot height like that and that's just a
great change in our project now if i was
to run our main file then you can see
that nothing is really changed and we
are in good position to continue doing
those manipulations to store more
variables now if you remember i said in
the tutorial that i used intentionally
those numbers so we could have an
accurate percentage of the weight size
for example there was a great reason
that i used the
180 value in the top frames height
because 180 times 4 is 720 so i can say
that i'd like to consume 25
of the entire height of our window and
those are things that are important
because we will not have too much hard
coded values so what we can do now is
having a file for some functions that
could be helpful to calculate those
stuff for example we could have a
function that will calculate how much is
20
of the entire height of our window right
so we can go ahead and use another
python file for that we can call it
utilities or
utils and we could have a function that
will calculate the percentage amount of
our height at first we could go ahead
and use
import settings so we will import the
settings of our project and we could go
ahead and use a function so let's call
this function height underscore prct
just a shortened version of percentage
right so we could go ahead and receive
here the percentage amount as a
parameter we make this a bit smaller and
then i can just go ahead and inside that
i can return the value relying on the
received argument in here so i can go
ahead and use return
and i can say settings
dot height divided by 100
and i can cover
this thing with parentheses and i can
multiply that
with the percentage amount so now i want
to validate that i have done a great job
writing this function right i don't
immediately want to call my functions
and just try to use them because i might
have a bug when i write a function and
that's also a great advantage locating
different functions in different files
because it will give you a huge
advantage debugging your stuff so for
example i could temporarily only execute
the utils.py file and just test my
function i could go ahead and try to
call it and passing year 25 and validate
that i will really receive 180 back so i
can go ahead and use
print
and execute utils so i'm not executing
my original project and now if you go
ahead and you see the value here you can
see that i really receive 180 and that's
good that means that we have done a
great job writing this function and now
i can really start using it in our
original project meaning in the main dot
py file so i can go ahead and
import all the utils file as well i can
say import utils and i can go ahead and
call the height percentage function i
can use utils dot height prct and pass
in 25 and again
this will have no effect this means that
we have done a great job only now we are
more dynamic and we do not hard code
values we are going to repeat ourselves
with the weight very quickly and then we
will move on to the next topic right so
i'm going to go here and i'm going to
use def height i mean
weight
prct
we will receive again percentage and we
will say return
open a parenthesis just so we can have a
cleaner look in this formula and we can
say
settings dot
width
divided into 100
multiplied by the percentage
so now i can go ahead and do pretty much
the same
in the different
hard coded values here so let's take a
look so in the top frame we use the
entire window so it makes sense to
change this just to the value of
settings.width right because it is
already 1440.
let's go to our left frame so in the
left frame we see that we use 25 percent
of the entire width so we can go ahead
and use utils
dot height prct excuse me
with prct i will change that and then i
will pass in 25 and
you can also see that in the height we
use 75 percent of our entire height so
that means that i can just use here
utils dot
height procedure and passing here 75 and
i can do the same when i want to locate
my left frame and you can notice how the
y axis value here is again 25 of the
entire height so i can say utils.height
prct
and pass in here 25
now let's see if we have done a great
job you can see that the result is again
perfect all right so now that we got
this then let me change those to the
original values and continue from here
to creating our last frame here so we
said that we'd like to have also one
more frame that is going to be in the
center of our page so that we will have
a frame that will be dedicated for our
game right so i will quickly go ahead
and create a center frame that will be
again equal to a frame
and this should be inside root the
background
should be maybe green so we can
separate it
i will need to change all of those to
black just in a few minutes
and then i'm going to say weight is
equal to utils dot width prct and this
time i'd like to use 75 of our entire
width and the height is going to be
again utils dot height velocity and this
will be 75
as well now the place method
will receive the following arguments so
the x value should be
utils dot
width piacity 25
because we want to start it from here
and the height meaning the y axis
should be the same right so i'm going to
duplicate that
and y and change this to
height plct
like that because we want this one to
start from here right so it's going to
take
360 pixels from the left and 180 pixels
from the top so now if we were to test
our code
then you're going to see that we have
just the expected result so now it's a
great time to change our frames to black
because we have done a great job we can
go ahead and change those to black now
what we are going to see is just a
window that is looking like a pure black
window but in the background in the real
python code we have two frames that are
divided just like we wanted so now that
i have changed the entire backgrounds to
black then we are just going to see the
same but in the background in the
original code we really have two frames
i mean three frames okay so until this
point we know that
we have a frame
here and we also have a frame that is
here now we said that around here we are
going to
write some information about the game
and here we will have the minesweeper
title
like that right but what we want to do
here in the center is actually
developing the board right the each cell
that a player is going to click on
should be here and here we should locate
all of our sales
now creating hard-coded
36 sales or 49 cells basically just
a huge amount of sales is going to be
hard so
here's the exact location that we want
to make our stuff a little bit more
dynamic we want to be able to
go ahead and do a for loop that will go
ahead and create those
kind of
cells dynamically now we also want the
behavior for each cell the kind of a
button behavior so-called because we
want the ability to click on something
and then next thing something will
happen in the game right we will see
some information about that cell so that
is the exact time for creating a class
that we can name it sell because we know
that for each cell we also like to give
some attributes like if the cell is mine
or not or if this is a cell that is
already opened or it is closed so that's
exactly the time that it is a great idea
thinking about creating a class that we
could name cell and we could create some
instances of that later on now just as a
quick example i'm going to delete that
after i'm going to show you the basic
example but here's how you can create a
button on a window using the tkinter
library right so let's use a random
variable like button one and that will
be equal to
button
like that now this button is going to
receive several arguments let's say that
we want this inside our center frame and
we want to give the background color of
blue and let's give it a text
sorry for missing the comma here let's
give it a text like first button
and then what i'm going to do
now is going to say button1 dot place
we will place it in
the first pixel in x axis and y axis in
the center frame so it should be in the
very top left position of that center
frame right so if we were to go ahead
and run this then you can see that i
have a button right there and it is
clickable now we know that we want to
abstract it with our custom class
because we need to give that
cell so-called some attributes as i
described earlier so that's why i want
to create a cell class and then we will
also see how the button class is going
to be involved within that cell class we
will start developing but let's actually
go ahead and start working on this right
so i just wanted to show you how to
create a button before we go ahead and
write some more code so i will go here
and create a cell
python file right and i will zoom in a
bit so everyone can see and i will use
class cell now temporarily i don't want
to inherit from the bottom class right
because it is not quite correct to say
that a cell is a kind of button we know
that we use inheritance to describe
kinds of things like dog is a kind of
animal so dog class should inherit from
a class that is an animal class but that
is not exactly the case here so i'm not
doing that and now that i created this
class let's go ahead and write the
constructor of our class now as we know
constructor is a method that is going to
be called immediately once a class is
being instantiated now i will receive
temporarily here
one parameter which i'm also going to
provide it a default value of false and
you can see that it is called is mine
right and i'm going to say self dot is
underscore mine is equal to is
underscore mine like the following right
so now that we have this let's see how
we are going to use it in our code so i
will go to my main.py file
and we'll scroll just above this comment
here run the window and i will
need to import the class for sure so
let's go ahead and use from cell which
is the file import the cell class like
that right and i'm just going to place
it in that line so we will have a
cleaner look
now i'm going to go here and i'm just
going to say c1 is equal to cell
and then i'm just going to leave it as
it is because it has a default value of
false and now that i have this then i
can just go ahead and run it and you can
see that the cloud the instantiation is
probably a good because we don't receive
an arrows now obviously we don't see any
button here because we just created a
custom class without relating it to the
button class that comes from this tk
interval library so now this is exactly
what we are going to do right we are
going to go to our cell file and we are
going to create a button instance that
is going to belong to each cell object
so what that means it means that this
self is going to receive one more
attribute that we could name it cell
button object something like that and
then we are going to assign it a button
object and that's how the relationship
between the cell objects and the button
object is going to be accomplished so
first things first i'm going to
close the game temporarily and i'm going
to go here and say
from tk inter import
you know what let's import just the
button class let's not use a
wild card import here and now i'm going
to go ahead and say that this should be
equal to
none at first and then what we're going
to do now is going to create an instance
method that will create this button for
us and i will assign it to self dot cell
button object let's take a look how we
are going to do that so i'm going to say
create
button object
and we will receive self only for now
and we are going to say here button is
equal to
a button like that and we are just
instantiating an instance of that button
class now currently we do not receive
any additional parameters other than the
self which is mandatory in instance
methods so we need to be receiving at
least one parameter that is quite
important which we can name it location
because we know that for each element
that we'd like to create in our window
we should be passing in a piece of
information that will make tk enter to
understand where it should locate that
element so if we receive a parameter
that is called location then i can just
pass in the location directly and then
whenever i call this method i will refer
to the actual center frame which will be
from the main dot py that's why i'm
receiving here the location parameter
right and just for a temporary example
let's give it also a random text like
text
like that just as a beginner and then
i'm going to say that self dot
cell btn object is going to be equal to
the object of the button that i have
just created and that is going to be
helpful because that will help me to
later on customize this button once i
assign this attribute into a button
object and you're gonna see just in a
minute how that is going to be extremely
helpful so
let's go ahead and split now vertically
so we can understand what we have done
here so on the left side we have the
cell
file and on the left side i'm going to
work on my main.py file so what i'm
going to do now here is going to go
ahead and say c1 dot create button
object because i can allow myself to
call that button and then i have the
ability to pass in the location because
center frame is a variable that is
accessible from the main dot py file
right so i can directly say center frame
as a parameter and then i can keep
working with my button object thanks to
the attribute assignment that i have
done
here right so i can go down and i can
say c1
dot cell btn object dot place
like that and i can say that i would
like to place it in x equals to zero and
y equals to zero just like we have done
in the beginning of this episode and now
that i have done this then it is a great
time testing our code so i'm going to
run this application and you're gonna
see that we are having that button so
that's a very fine start developing this
application and spreading the code in
different files so it will be more
maintainable and more readable all right
so now that we have done this then we
need to understand that we are going to
have some problems in the future if we
will keep using that place method in
order to place our elements now in order
to show you the problem that i'm talking
about i'm going to create here one more
instance of the cell class that we came
up with so i'm going to say that c2 is
equal to cell
like the following and then i'm going to
say c2.38
button object and it's going to be
center frame again
and then i want this cell just near the
first cell right so
i should be saying something like c2 dot
cell button object dot place
and then we should know dynamically
how much pixels we should jump
right in order to place it exactly in
the location that we want but that's
going to be a lot of headache and a lot
of trouble always knowing the exact
location that we want to pass because
for example let's say that i will pass
in x equals to 20 and y equals to zero
and
run our game now you can see here that
the right button looks like it is before
the left button because we can
almost not see the text on the left
button here so we can try to increase
this amount of x to 40 something like
that and re-execute our game and you can
see that now it is much better but when
we want to deal around creating multiple
elements dynamically then maybe using
the place mode isn't the best option
here so we need to consider changing our
placement method when we use tk inter
when it comes to tens of elements that
we want to create dynamically and we can
do this by changing our method from
place to grid now what grid does it
takes the parent element which is quite
right there and it turns the parent
element into columns and rows now the
beauty is it counts from zero the
columns and rows so for example if we
want to place a button right there then
we can say that we'd like to grid that
and then give it some values that will
be considered as the column number and
the row number let's see this in action
right so it might be a little bit
confusing to understand in the theory
but now that we will go ahead and code
this it will be easier to understand so
i'm going to delete everything from here
and go back to pycharm and actually go
ahead and change the placement method
from grid on both of those buttons here
so i'm going to go to my c1 and i'm
going to say
grid and then i'm going to pass in here
column
equals to
zero
and row equals to zero like that now i'm
going to grab those arguments and
pass in the same
changing this method to grid as well and
then you're gonna see the difference
when i will be saying here row equals to
one and now if we were to go ahead and
run our program then you can see that we
have a difference this text here is used
to be at column zero row zero but this
one used to be placed at column zero row
one and that is the reason you see the
second button under the first button and
if i was to
change this to zero and make that one
meaning column equals to one then you're
gonna see those buttons one near each
other which is perfect and it will be
helpful when we want to create tons of
buttons in order to start preparing for
the minesweeper game alright so now that
we understood how the grid method works
then we are going to start creating
those cells like we want in our
minesweeper game now that's something
that we can achieve with a nested for
loop so let me show you how it's going
to look like so it will be easier to
maintain in the future
and let's delete this first so i'm going
to start my first for loop and i'm going
to say for x in
range of 5 for example now range is just
a function that is responsible to
generate all the integers in the given
range of numbers if i was to only pass
in here 5 then it will generate 0 1 2 3
and 4 like that right so i'm going to go
inside here and then i'm going to say
for y
in range of 5 so i'm basically achieving
here the behavior of creating 25 buttons
because i have a loop that iterates five
times inside another loop that iterates
as well five times so
now i can go inside of that and i can
say that c is equal to cell
so i'm instantiating an object of it and
then i can go ahead and say create btn
object and as the location i will pass
in center frame for sure so now that we
have created the button object then i
can access it with the property that we
have created previously which was
cell btn object and i can use the grid
option and then i can pass in column
equals to
y and i can say row is equal to weeks
like that and now let's see the result
of that so i'm going to run that and you
can see how beautiful it looks like
right so we are already starting to see
something similar to a minesweeper game
and that's perfect now what we can do
instead of hard coding in the five on
those for loops we can actually allow
ourselves to go to the settings file and
right here a new setting that can look
like grid size then we can decide that
it is equal to any number we like to i
will say 6 just because this was the
number that i showed in the beginning of
this entire series as an example game
and then i'm going to go here and say
settings
dot grid size now if you remember i
import the entire settings file right
there right so i can access the grid
size variable and i can also say here
the same thing
and then i can just run our program
again and you can see how it looks like
so we have a six
columns and rows like that and that's
just a great starter now before we go
ahead and sorry about the confusion here
i think it will be better if we will say
column equals to x and row equals to y
because if we were to for example change
this to three and not the settings dot
grid size
then it's going to be more accurate to
say that we have three rows right one
two and three so that's why i'm going to
stick for
those column equals tweaks and row
equals to y
like the following and then now i can
just convert this back to
settings.gridsize and continue from here
all right so now that we totally
understood this then we probably want to
also understand how we can assign events
to our buttons now an event is basically
a list of actions that you want to take
once you click on a button now we said
in the beginning of this entire series
that we would like to differentiate
between the action that we are taking
when we left click on a button or when
we right click on a button right because
those are two different actions in a
minesweeper game so
that is going to be very cool designing
this thing in the minesweeper game
giving the events for our buttons is
actually very fun part of our game so
let's see how we can do that so i'm
going to go to my cell.py file and
here's the exact location that we can
start assigning some events to the
buttons that we create because that's
exactly the location that we create our
button object we can also go ahead and
assign it an event now let's go ahead
and write this so when we want to assign
an event to a button then we want to
work with a specific method that is
called bind so with bind we can actually
go ahead and say that we like to print
something when we left click on a button
and let's see how we are going to do
that so we're going to need to pass in
two arguments the first argument being
the key that is clicked on the button
and as well as what is the function that
you want to be executing once you
click on whatever button you click at so
first things first we want to say that
we want to do something when we left
click on a button and the convention
with the tk inter for passing in the
left click is going to be something like
the following so i'm going to use the
less than sign and i'm going to say
button capitalized
dash one
greater than sign so
button dash one is just a convention of
saying left click button dash three is
going to be right click and we're gonna
see this just in a second and then we
also like to say that we'd like to
execute some function right that's going
to be the second argument of the bind
method so let's start with the most
minimalistic function that we can come
up with so i'm going to create a method
inside my cell class which i'm going to
be calling left click
actions like that and that's going to
also receive self for sure it's an
instance method and then it's only going
to say
i am left clicked just as a basic
example i'm going to leave it as it is
and now that we have done this then i
can easily pass in the reference for
that method so it's not going to be like
left click actions and i'm going to
call this method like that besides i'm
just going to give it the reference like
the following so pay attention that you
are not calling this method you are only
passing the reference of that method so
now that we got this then let's check it
out and see if that is going to work for
us so i'm going to go here and make this
a little bit bigger and i'm going to try
to click on one of those cells here and
you can see that we have an error now
you can see that it says here
left click actions takes one positional
argument but two were given now that
might be a familiar error that you maybe
saw in
my oop series but basically this means
that
this self-click actions tries to
pass in two arguments when it tries to
call the left click actions method now
that means that this method needs to be
receiving one more additional parameter
in order to make this
event assignment successfully and that
comes from just as a convention of
kinder it needs to be receiving one more
parameter when you assign something to
an event
it might be a little bit confusing but
that's the way that events are working
in tk inter so by convention i'm only
going to receive in an initial parameter
that i'm going to call it event now this
should be enough because tinter tries to
pass in two arguments so passing here
another parameter here should be perfect
so i'm going to re-execute
the program and then i'm going to try to
click on some buttons and you can see
that we have a great result here for
each button that i'm clicking i'm
receiving this text of i am left clicked
and that is perfect
now i'd also like to add in here one
more line which will be responsible to
print in the
info that comes to that event parameter
and you're gonna see that it is actually
filled in with some information that
tkinter passes in
in the background so now let's again run
our game and if i was to click on
something then you can see that i
received some info about what was the
event that is occurred so you can see
that i have a button press event state
equals to mod 1 just basically some
metadata about the event that has been
occurred in that moment and you can also
see that i receive the values of x axis
and y axis
for the exact location that it was
clicked so that is just a great
background information that you can go
ahead and do something with it if you
like to now you can clearly see why this
bind method requires from us to receive
one more parameter when we assign a
function as a event that needs to be
called now it might be a great idea to
also prepare the bind method for our
right clicks so i'm going to minimize
this console and i'm just going to
duplicate this line and i'm going to say
that we should be also binding the
button dash 3 so this will stand for
right click
and this will stand for left
click now you might also want to try
button dash 2 if button dash 3 doesn't
work for you just for safety if 3
doesn't work when you right click try
also button dash 2 if you have any
further troubles then let me know this
in the comment section all right so i'm
going to say here right click actions
and obviously i'm going to go here and
say
deaf right click actions and again i'm
going to receive this event
and i'm just going to do the same right
so at first i'm going to print the event
and i'm going to say
i am
right click so we can differentiate
between the two and i'm going to again
execute our game
and i know you can't see this but i'm
going to
right click on that and you can see that
now we have the
text in the console that is the exact
same like the right click action so that
is great and we were able to actually
assign some events to all of our buttons
dynamically all right so in that episode
we are going to focus a lot in our cell
class because we're gonna need to write
some logic to prepare the mind sweeper
game that's going to be very fun to
write all of those new attributes that
we'd like to receive in this cell class
and as well as writing all the methods
that will be responsible to write the
logic of our mind sweeper game so
there's going to be a lot of
object-oriented stuff that we're going
to write in that episode and that's
going to be very cool doing all of those
all right so first things first we might
want to start by increasing the size of
our buttons to make them more readable
and that is achievable by going ahead to
the instantiation of our button class
inside this create button object and
passing in some additional arguments
that will be responsible to really
increase the size of our buttons now
before preparing the project i figured
out that passing in weight equals to
12 and height equals to 4 are great
values when you play minesweeper where
it has 36 cells now you can actually go
ahead and pass in here some formula that
will be responsible to make the buttons
smaller if the grid size gets bigger but
in order to make that simple then i'm
just going to leave it as it is and i'm
going to assume throughout the tutorial
that we are only going to play the
minesweeper game with 36 buttons meaning
the grid size being 6
which is that value that i am talking
about so now i'm going to execute my
main file and that's how it looks like
right now and that's just bigger and
more readable and more comfortable to
play with alright so now that we came up
with this then we gonna need to take our
next steps in order to have some more
info about each of our cells now for
example we don't have even one single
indicator about which cell is what until
now because the only thing that we know
about each of our cells is the fact that
it is just writing a text in all of
those 36 buttons but it could have been
great if we could have some indicators
about each of our cells in here so for
example until this point we know that we
have 36 buttons
so we have those
and we have those right but we don't
have even one single indicator about
each
cell so for example it could have been
nice if this cell for example could have
an attribute like x
equals to zero and y equals to zero
because that is just something that
represents that cell specifically that
means that we could receive some more
attributes in that cell and the same
goes for example for that cell here
right it could have been great if we
could say that this
cell had an attribute like x equals to 5
and y
equals to 5. and the reason i
use this 5 and 5 in here is because we
start to count from zero so zero one two
three four five in the same counting
method from the
top to bottom like that so let's go
ahead and receive some more attributes
in this class so i'm going to go to my
init method and i'm going to say x and y
like that and make sure that you add
those commas and then i'm going to use
the self assignment self.x equals to x
then i'm going to do the same for self.y
self.y is equal to y like that and now
that i have this then i can actually go
ahead and go to my main.py file and pass
in those numbers because i iterate over
those numbers when i create those cells
so you can already see that we have some
problems instantiating the cell because
we need to pass in some mandatory
arguments and once we do that then we
are totally fine and now that we have
some attributes in each of our cells we
can actually use those to temporarily
display different text on our cells so
we can change this into a formatted
string for example and we can use the
reference to self.x
comma
self
dot y inside the curly brackets and now
i can execute our game and you can see
that now we have some attributes where
each attribute represents a unique cell
right so we know that x equals to 5 y
equals to 5 is that cell here and we
know that 2.2 is that cell over there so
that's a great starting to prepare the
algorithm that we want to write to have
the minesweeper game
alright so now that we have done this
then we want to prepare designing
creating some mines between all of those
cells now we know that in a minesweeper
game when we start each game the game
picks up some random cells and it
converts them into cells that are
forbidden to click meaning minds so we
need to somehow write an algorithm that
will be responsible to take a couple of
cells and turn them into minds now we
know that we already have an attribute
that is called is mine and by default
all of those are false so now we gonna
need to write a method that will pick up
some cell objects and will convert those
attributes from being is mine equals to
false
to is mine equals to
true so that we will have a great
beginning of the minesweeper game going
on now we know that temporarily all of
the cells are not mines because we
always assign false but that's something
that we are going to change just right
now so in order to start designing this
then it's a great idea to have a static
method which we can call from the main
dot py file right after we instantiate
the cell objects so it's a great idea to
just have a method that is not belong to
each instance besides it is belong
globally to the class and that's the
definition of a static method so i'm
going to use that decorator of static
method and i'm going to say def
randomize
mines like that so this means that it
takes a couple of cells and turns them
into mines
so
that is exactly where we would like to
write some logic to turn some cells into
mines
so temporally i'm going to pass in the
past so we'll not have any errors and
now let's see how we are going to do
that all right so first things first we
need to understand how we can store all
of our instances inside the list and
there's a great reason that we want to
do that in that stage because we
instantiate 36 instances but we don't
have any control how we can take further
actions with those 36 instances that we
instantiate from this cell class that we
have here so in order to have a
collection of all of our instances in
one place then it is a great idea to
create a class attribute inside our cell
class which we can name something like
all and that's going to be
an empty list temporarily now we're
going to append the objects of this cell
class to that all
variable and that's something that we
can do dynamically inside our init
method because this method is the method
that is being called every time that you
create an instance so it totally makes
sense to go ahead and do here something
that will be responsible to append
the object to the cell.all list so we
can have all the instances of this cell
class in one place and that means that
we're gonna need to say here cell
dot
all now that's the way that you can
access class attributes inside your
class you might have thought about using
just all but when we work with classes
you always need to specify the class
name as a prefix when you access your
class attributes so
we can say cell dot all dot append and
then we could add the object itself
which is self so now that we have done
this then we probably like to test if
that is something that's going to work
so we can go to our main.py file and
right after we instantiate all of those
objects in those lines we can say print
cell
dot all so we should see a list with 36
elements inside this
console here so you can see that this is
exactly the result you'll see that we
have
probably 36 elements in here that's also
we can test
with using the len built-in function
before that you can see that we have 36
now you probably noticed that the
objects the way that the objects were
represented in the console was not too
much friendly it could have been great
if we could override this setting that
we could see the objects nicer and more
friendly and that's something that we
can do by overriding some
magic methods so we can go to that soul
class and we can override some magic
method that will be responsible to
change the way that the object is being
represented and i'm talking about a
magic method that is called our epr like
that so we can go ahead and say that
this should return
a formatted string that could look like
the following cell
and then we will pass in here self.x
and
self dot
y
so that's just more friendly string that
will represent each object more friendly
so besides seeing random ids then we can
see real friendly names for each of our
objects
and if we want to test that this is
going to work i can again allow myself
to execute this main.py file and
confirm that and you can see that now i
have
way more friendly objects in here you
can see that we have perfect result
all right so now that we understood this
then i want to work side by side left
side will be the main.py file and the
right side will be the cell.py file now
i want to check out each time that i'm
doing a great job in writing some logic
inside these randomized mines so i'm
going to go ahead and right after i
instantiate those i'm going to call this
randomize mines static method so i'm
going to say cell
dot randomize mines like that and i'm
going to leave it as it is and every
time that i add a piece of code inside
this method then i want to execute the
entire game to see that i did not screw
up anything all right so first things
first in order to randomize the things
in order to pick some random things from
a collection we need to work with the
library that is called random so i'm
going to go to the first line here i'm
into the second line and i'm going to
say here import renault now random has a
very specific method that is responsible
to pick randomly some elements from the
given collection now i'm going to show
simpler example at first so i'm going to
go here and say that i have a list
and again that's going to be just a
simple example to show you how that
method i'm talking about works so i'm
going to have
a list
with
three names all right
i'm going to have g michael and paul and
then let's say that i want to randomly
pick two names each time so i'm going to
go ahead and say random.simple
sample is a method that at first
accepts the collection that you want to
pick randomly elements from so it will
be my list and then the second argument
is the amount of elements that you want
to pick each time so since i want to
pick two names each time then i'm going
to pass in here two so
let's also assign this entire statement
to a variable so i'm going to call this
picked names
right and then i'm going to just print
it
so print
picked names now pay attention that i
call this method so we should be seeing
the results when i execute this game so
when i go ahead and execute our program
then you can see that i receive jim and
michael and for our next run we can
totally receive different names you can
see that this time i received jim and
paul so that's exactly what we want to
do with our minds we want to randomly
pick
some cells some cell objects and then
just change the attribute of is mine to
true because all of them are false so
now that we understood this let's go
ahead and write the needed logic inside
the randomized minds so my list is going
to be cell.all because that is the
collection that i want to pick some
objects randomly from it right so i'm
going to delete this line right after we
understood how the sample works i'm
going to change this variable to
picked cells
because that is just a more realistic
variable name and then i'm going to
delete this line temporally i'm going to
jump a line here so it will be easier to
see the arguments that are passed and
the collection that i will be passing
here will be cell dot all because the
cell dot all includes all the instances
right and then we need to decide for an
integer which will be responsible to be
the element count that should be picked
now if we have about 36 cells then it
might be a great idea to pick at least
as a quarter of a value of it so maybe
nine cells to convert them into a mine
will not make this game too much
difficult to basically win it right so
i'm going to pass in here nine
temporarily just to see how that is
going to work
then i'm going to say print picked cells
and
execute our program and then you can see
that we have randomly nine cell objects
that have been picked in here so that's
an extremely useful method that we can
go ahead and use it to pick up some
cells and convert them into mines
so now that we have a picked sales
collection meaning a picked sales list
then we can actually iterate over the
peaked cells objects and only changing
the attribute of is mine from false to
true
so let's go ahead and besides printing
pixels use a for loop that will look
like the following so i can say for
pixel
in
picked cells
and then now i'm iterating over each
object so i can say pixel
dot is underscore mine
equals to
true now
the is mind is coming from here because
we already know that we have such an
attribute and we just want to change
that to
true and now that we have this then
let's go ahead and run our program and
we should not be seeing anything but in
the background the attribute has been
totally overridden by the value of true
now if you really want to test that you
can go ahead and
after calling the randomized mines in
the left side you can go ahead and use
something like for
c in
cell dot all
then print the c dot is mine so we
should be seeing some trues some falses
and that's going to be the final testing
that will really show us that we were
able to change some attributes and you
can see that this is exactly the result
so we have done a great job picking up
some random objects and just turn them
into mines and that's just a one way
that you can do that okay so now that we
have done this then it totally makes
sense to delete those sort of debug
lines
now we need to figure out how we are
going to be dynamic deciding the value
of this picked mines amount right so we
can go ahead and use the settings.py
file to actually use some formula to
calculate how many minds we want in our
game so we can go ahead and use here one
more setting that we can name mines
count and that might be equal to
something like the following so i will
open up the parenthesis and i will say
between those
grid size
power of two and then i can divide it by
four because
in that game currently we have 36 cells
because we iterate over the value of six
two times so it makes sense that we
write such a formula right so six power
of two divided by four is nine and that
is pretty much the value that we look to
have when we want to have at least a
fair minesweeper game we don't want to
have
half of the value we don't want to have
like 27 mines because that is just going
to be too difficult to win that game so
about a quarter of that value is just
fine now you might also ask yourself
what is going to happen if one day i
will change the grid size to 7
so 7 power of 2 is 49 and divided by 4
is 12.25 and that is just not good
because mine's count should be an
integer so i'm just going to add here
one more first slash and when you use
double first slash it is forcing it to
be in an integer it totally ignores the
remainder so we can just add here one
more first slash and that will be okay
now i can go back to my cell dot py file
and i can
refer to that value settings dot
mines
count and i see that we don't have any
import line about the settings so you
can just go ahead and use import
settings up top and we should be fine
all right so in that episode we are
going to design what we should do when
we left click on a cell so first things
first we should be deleting the text
that we have wrote to each of the cells
here which represents the x and y axis
values so let's go ahead and delete this
first so i'm going to
take that line off because this used to
be the text of the cell so i'm just
going to make that to be equal to
nothing and then we need to decide what
we are going to display here once we
left click on a cell so let me
re-execute the game like that and now we
can see that we don't have anything so
the expected action here is whenever we
click
left click excuse me on sl then we
should be displaying a number
which that number will represent how
many mines there are surrounded that
cell so what that means
it means that if that's a mine and
that's a mine and as well as this one
then we should be displaying here
three because this cell should figure
out how many mines there are surrounding
that cell let's take one more example
here so let's assume that we clicked
here
right then this cell should start
thinking how many minds there are
surrounded the cells so this means we
talk about all those cells let's say
that we have a mine here right we have
one mind there and all of those are not
mines so we should be displaying here
one
right so that's going to be the main
goal in that episode and it's going to
take a lot of algorithms that we should
be writing inside methods inside the
cell class so it's going to be extremely
challenging and also fun doing that and
let's go ahead and get started alright
so i'm going to start by scrolling down
to the left click actions and then i'm
going to delete everything here and
start writing here some actions that we
need to take now one of the first things
that we want to write here is an if
conditional that will check if that cell
is actually a mine and i can do that by
writing if self dot is mine so the
reason that i can do that is because i
know that in the beginning of the game i
already call this method that is called
randomized minds which takes a couple of
cell objects and then it sets
is mine equals to true so i can totally
do that and then if the clicked cell is
a mine then i want to start taking
several actions so those several actions
are also going to be located under a
method that we can write right now so if
self dot is mine then i can go ahead and
say self dot show underscore mind
something like that and that is just a
theory i know that show mine is not a
method that exists right now but that's
what we're going to do just right now
i'm going to go out of that method and
then i'm going to say def
show mine
and i will receive self as a perimeter
for sure all right so in that method i'm
going to basically write the actions
that will be responsible to display
this cell as a mine now we know that
here we should write a logic
to
interrupt the game
and display a message
a message
that player
lost right something like that but i'm
not going to do that temporarily because
it is going to be too much annoying to
stop and terminate the game every time
that i click on a mine while we develop
that game so converting the background
of that cell into a red background color
should be enough temporally so i'm going
to just say here something like the
following
self dot cell
underscore button object and then i'm
going to configure the background color
of it so if you remember when we use
tkinter objects we can use this
configure method which will be
responsible to configure our elements so
as an example i can go ahead and say
here bg equals to red now that is
equivalent to what we have done with the
frame let me show you that by splitting
vertically you can see that we took our
window here and we used dot configure bg
equals to black so what we do here we do
here an action that is quite equivalent
whenever we click on a cell we check if
that is a mine and if it is then we'll
launch that method which will be
responsible to configure the background
color of that to red and that is just a
perfect beginning so if we
run our game
and we click on a couple of cells
then you can see that this is a mine so
that's why it has been colored to red so
that's a great start and i realized that
i had a typing mistake here so this
should be a logic to interrupt the game
and display a message that's player lost
all right so now that we have done this
then we should be also designing what we
should do if the cell
is not a mine so here is the exact
location that i should be say else and
then i should launch a method that will
say self.show underscore
cell right and here is going to be the
complex stuff because we need to display
a number that will represent the amount
of mines that are surrounded the clicked
cell so i'm going to go here and i'm
going to indent out from this left click
actions and i'm going to say here def
show
underscore cell and we will receive
yourself let's say pass here and explain
what we're going to do here just in a
second now i zoomed out a bit to the
beginning of our class because in order
to explain what we should do now i'm
going to again bring back the text that
we used to have here which was self.x
comma self.y because i want to display
the x's x and x's y values because
that's going to be helpful to explain
what i'm about to explain right now so i
execute the game here you can see that
again we have the x's x and y values now
in order to start calculating the amount
of mines in the surrounded cells
whenever we click somewhere then we
should be using those x's x and y values
for sure because think about the
situation that we clicked
here right let's say that we clicked
here right now so we should start
iterating
over the cells that are surrounded that
cell and check if each one of those are
mines or not and then somehow we should
be collecting the amount of mines and
displayed here so that's a lot of
actions that we should be taking now we
can understand that
having a method that will receive the x
and y as a parameter and then will give
us back
the object of a cell is going to be
extremely helpful because think of a
situation that you click on that cell
you want to check the attributes of this
cell
of that cell and also
this cell so we can already start
understanding that
if we will have a method that will
return the cell object depending on the
given x and y values is going to be
extremely extremely helpful so that's
going to be the first step that we
should be taking right now we should be
writing a method that we can call it get
cell by axis and then this will return
us back an object of the cell so let's
go ahead and write that all right so i'm
going to go here
to that line above the show cell and i'm
going to say
something like death
get cell
by
axus and then i'm going to receive here
x and
y like that and the actions that we want
to do here is basically return a cell
object
based on the values of x and y
that's all that's everything that we
want to do here in this method so now
we know that we have this list that is
called all and we can basically start
iterating over this list of objects to
find the sale object that we need based
on those x and y values so i'm going to
go ahead and start with a basic
filtration that will help us to give us
back the cell object that we need so i'm
going to say here for cell
in cell dot all and just pay attention
that i'm using the class name so c
should be in upper case and then i'm
going to say something like the
following
if cell dot x is equal to the given x
argument and
cell dot y
is equal to the given y value then we
should be using here return
cell like that now the reason that i can
do this it is because whenever i'm going
to have a match in those x and y
attributes then i can immediately stop
my iteration and just return that object
and that's going to be helpful because
whenever we want to display the cell
then we immediately want to see what is
going on inside the surrounding cells so
that's a method that is going to be
really helpful again and that's going to
be something that we are going to
understand in a couple of minutes all
right so the next thing that i want to
do now is to call that method and
basically print the result of that
inside the show cell now just a kind
reminder if we take a look in the left
click actions if the click cell is not a
mine we are entering here in the else
statement and we call this show cell
method so if we go here and say print
self dot get cell by axis and we pass in
just random values like i don't know
zero
comma zero then we should see the object
specifically where the x attribute is
equal to zero and the y attribute is
equal to zero and that is not going to
be a matter which cell i'm clicking here
because i just
bring the object where x and y are equal
to zero vote all right so let me launch
the game now and see what is going on
here so if the click cell is not a mine
then we should see the object right so
let me
make the console bigger and i'm just
going to click on
zero five and that was a mine so we did
not see anything on the console let's
click on here and you can see that i see
the object cell
0
comma 0 and that was a mine
going to click here this is a mine as
well
that's not a mine so that is a perfect
result i'm also going to click here you
can see that we have a perfect method
that returns the object based on the
given x and y values so let me show you
in a separated window why that's going
to be helpful having such a method so
imagine again that we are going to click
on 1.1 as an example right so we're
gonna need to collect all those eight
cells that are surrounded the clicked
cell so this means that now we have the
control to bring this one that one and
this and that and this and that
and also those two here so in order to
show what we should be doing right now
with the gate cell by axis method then
i'm going to work on this side notepad
that i have here so let's imagine a
situation that we really clicked on 1.1
so if we click on 1.1 then we should be
bringing the
sales that are 0.0
0.1 0.2
right so those are going to be
those three
right
and then
let's continue on so we should be also
bringing 1.0
and
2.0 and those are going to be
those two
and let's continue on for again clicking
on 1.1 we should be also bringing the
sale of 2.1 2.2
and those are
just going to be
those two and then we also have 1.2 that
we should bring and that's going to be
also
written here so you can see that we have
a formula that we should be following so
now let's go ahead and implement this in
our code so i'm going to delete all the
drawings here and i'm going to go back
to our actual code so first things first
i'm going to delete this one
and then i'm going to just do something
like the following i'm going to
make a list that is going to be called
surrounded
cells and that's going to be equal to a
list and that list is going to include
those eight objects now those eight
objects could be basically pulled from
this get cell by axis
method so first it's going to be dot get
cell by axis and for 1.1 we should be
decreasing the x by
1 and we should be also decreasing the y
by
1. so first one is going to be self dot
x minus 1
the second value is going to be self dot
y minus 1 like that so we can allow
ourselves to check the first
cell that we should be pulling right so
let's go to the second one and don't
forget to add here a comma because we
have a list that is going to include
eight elements and we should be comma
separating them so the second one is
going to be self dot get sale by axis
and now the formula is going to be
decreasing the x by one
and the y value is going to be the same
because as you can see the y value here
and the here are the same so i'm just
going to pass in here self dot y and
again comma separated and in order to be
organized i also going to say here v to
mark it as a checked cell so the third
one is going to be self dot get cell by
axis and again the self.x is going to be
decreased by one but this time the y
value is going to be increased by one
because that is two here so this is now
also checked i'm at i'm going to add
here a comma and now i'm going to say
self.getcell by xs
i'm going to pass in the same self.x
because the next value is 1 and then the
y value is decreased by one so it's
going to be
dot y minus one like that and that's
also checked
and now i'm going to jump on to the next
one it's going to be get cell by axis
self dot x
plus one because the next one is 2.0 and
then i'm going to pass here self.y
minus one right and that's the fifth
value i'm going to check that
the sixth one is going to be
so the previous one was the fifth value
and that's is that's going to be the
sixth value so self.x
plus one again
and the y value should be the same
going to close that add a comma mark it
as a checked
so i'm going to do this two more times
self
dot
get cell by axis now you can pay
attention that both x and y values are
increased by one so i'm going to to
exactly like that
plus one for both and then the last
value is going to be self dot get cell
by axis
we're gonna be passing the same x value
and then the self.y is going to be
increased by one and we can allow
ourselves to basically
write a check for all the eight cells so
now
that we have done this then we can allow
ourselves to first print it to see if we
have done a great job right so i'm going
to say print
surrounded
cells to see that we have done a
wonderful job and let's go ahead and
check ourselves so i'm going to execute
game
stop and rerun so
we are going to click on 1.1 and we
should be see a list with eight objects
let's follow up what is going on here so
0 0
0.1
0.2
1.0 2.0 2.1 2.2
and 1.2 so
perfect right perfect job we brought
everything that we need and if we count
this one two three four five six seven
eight it really seems like we have done
a wonderful job now
the problematic thing could be if we
click on a cell like 0.0 because this
has three surrounded cells so this might
lead to not working but let's see if
that's going to work i believe it's
going to work and it is going to pull
the three objects like expected 1.0 0.1
and 1.1 so i'm going to click on 0.0 and
you can see that that is quite what
happening but you can see that we
receive none for all the five because
what is going on here
if we click on 0.0 then at some point
this gate cell by axis is going to
receive negative values because whenever
we click on 0.0 then a minus 1 value
could be passed so we need to eliminate
those nuns when we write this surrounded
sales list and that's something that
we're going to take care later on but
until now a perfect job bringing on
these surrounded cell objects and let's
continue from here all right so now that
we have done this then we said a minute
ago that we are going to take care of
the non values that we had inside our
list now that is something that could be
done by list comprehension now a list
comprehension means to create a list by
a one-liner that is going to immediately
take care of something that you want to
take care right now so in order to take
care of eliminating the non-values
inside the list then you can use a list
comprehension expression in order to
handle the known values and just
get them out of your list so what we are
going to do now is we are going to
override the surrounded sales list but
we're gonna need to use a one-liner list
comprehension in order to eliminate the
nons so that's going to be something
like the following so surrounded sales
is going to be equal to a new list which
is going to look like the following so
what we really want to do is to have the
exact same list but we want to eliminate
the nuns so that is achievable by doing
something like that so you can use a
one-liner for loop inside your list in
order to take care of something
immediately for example let me show you
how we can do a for loop in one line so
you can say
sell
for sell in surrounded sales and now
that we have done this let's see the
results right so i'm going to print
surrounded cells and pay attention that
i'm overriding the value of this one by
again using the same value and assigning
something new to that so i'm going to
again execute our main.py
and
let's show what is going to happen if we
click on 1.1 you can see that the result
is pretty much the same and if i was to
click on 0.0 then again the results are
same but whenever you used a list
comprehension
and you include inside of that a
one-liner for loop then you can use an
if statement that will
take care of something that you don't
want right now so i can go ahead and use
an expression here that will look like
if
cell meaning the iterated value
is not known so that's going to
eliminate out our known values and that
is exactly what we want so again i can
re-execute our program and see if that's
going to work so if we were to click on
0.0
we see the perfect result right we see
three elements inside our list and
that's also something that we may want
to test with a cell like 0.1 because if
we count the surround sales then we have
here 1 2 3 4 and five so if we click on
that then you can see we have five
elements inside our list so that is a
perfect way bringing the surrounded
cells when we click on some cell all
right so now that we understood this
then i'm going to move all those lines
of code into a separated method so that
we could have a property that is going
to represent the surrounded sales object
now a property is basically like an
attribute that is read only and you can
mark those attributes as read-only
attributes by using a decorator so let
me show you how that's going to work so
i'm going to just copy everything from
here and you know what just cut it like
ctrl x and not copy and then i'm going
to say
def surrounded cells and this will
receive self and i'm just going to
leave those code snippets here and then
i'm going to say something like
return
cells and i'm going to be changing those
variable names to sales and also this
one
and as well as
that one now the reason that i'm doing
this it is because i don't want to have
the same
variable name as the same as the name of
my method because that could lead to a
lot of problems and i said that i will
be converting this into a read-only
attribute and that's achievable by the
property decorative so above this method
i'm going to say add property and now
you can just use it as an attribute
exactly like the attributes that we have
here in the init so now that we have
done this
then i can allow myself to go back to
show cell and validate that i have done
a great job and i can use here self dot
surrounded cells and you can see that i
have an auto completion and that is just
perfect now i can access my surrounded
cells by accessing this property from
here all right so now that we have a
method that brings in the surrounded
cells
objects then we need to iterate over the
surrounded cells objects and identify
which one of those are mines and which
of those are not mines so that's going
to be taking in one more method that is
going to be responsible for that so i'm
going to again create a method here that
is going to look like
surrounded cells
mines length and
you can understand what this method is
going to do it is going to
count the mines that are in the
surrounded cells whenever a cell is
clicked so i'm going to make this logic
as easy as saying first
counter equals to zero and then i'm
going to iterate over the surrounded
sales objects so it's going to be for
cell
in self dot surrounded sales and i'm
going to check if cell dot
is underscore mine
then i'm going to increase the counter
by one so it's going to be counter plus
equals one and at the end of the day i
want to return the counter back and just
use it so it's going to be getting out
of those for loops and if conditional
and then just use return counter like
that now just like we have done with the
self dot surrounded cells i can also
allow myself to use this surrounded
cells mines length as a read-only
attribute so i'm again going to go above
this method and i'm going to mark it as
a property like that by using this
decorator now i did not mention this
early on but if you don't know what is
the property decorator then i have an
object oriented programming series that
you can go ahead and take a look and i
bet that it's going to be a very
informative video if you never heard
about this property decorator which is
an extremely useful thing when we write
object-oriented programs all right so
now that we have done this then i can
allow myself to do something like the
following so i want to go inside the
show cell and i just want to be seeing
the length of the minds meaning the
amount of minds that i have whenever i
click on a cell so that is just going to
be a great test for our game so if we
click on a cell then we can allow
ourselves to print self dot surrounded
sales mines
and let's go ahead and see if that's
going to work so i'm going to execute my
game and for example let's assume
that i'm going to click on 0.0 and that
is a mine and i'm fine with it and
that's also a mine and let's click on
here so you can see that i see three in
the console right because i clicked on
1.1 and what that means it means that
over here we have
three mines
so let's keep on and continue clicking
on some cells so we already have two
mines here and we should be having one
more inside these surrounded cells so
not here not here
not here not here
also not here okay so we have a mine
here and if we click on here so
that's not a mine as well so that is
perfect that is really perfect because
around this one around this one cell
here we have three minds and this means
that we have completed writing this
logic in the best way that we can all
right so there's going to be one more
thing that we want to do immediately
when we go ahead and click on a cell and
that's going to be displaying the number
of mines that are surrounded that cell
so now that we have control
with these surrounded cells mines length
then we can allow ourselves to change
the behavior of this short cell method
and we can go ahead and just configure
the text of our cell to display the
amount of minds surrounded that cell so
that's going to be something like the
following it's going to be by accessing
to the cell button object and
configuring the text so i'm going to use
the configure method again and i'm just
going to say text is equal to
self dot surrounded cells mine's length
and that should be enough and now i can
really allow myself to delete the
original text that we had previously so
i'm going to scroll up and i'm going to
go back to the method that helps us to
create the button object and i'm going
to take off these text from here
just delete that
and then i'm going to execute our game
run the program and let's click on some
cell so you can see that we have two and
this means that we have a cell
maybe here that is not a mind so this
means that for sure that is a mine and
that's a mine as well so perfect now we
really start to have a really game going
on and that is pretty much what we want
to do in that tutorial we wanted to
write the logic to display the amount of
minds that are located
in the surrounded cells whenever we
click on a cell so in this episode we
are going to design some functionalities
that will be helpful to display more
information about the game for example
currently we know that there are 36
cells that are clickable that we can
click on but now if i click here we know
that we have 35 cells that we can click
so we need to interactively display this
kind of information in our window that's
going to be interesting to see how we
can develop such a functionality and in
addition we are going to develop a
functionality that will be responsible
to automatically open all these
surrounded cells if the clicked cell
length is zero exactly like in this case
because obviously if we know that there
are zero mines surrounding this cell
then there is no point to not
automatically click on this and that and
this and that and that so the reason for
that is because there are always going
to be zero mines surrounding that cells
so to click on them is safe so we are
going to develop a functionality that
will do this automatically for us and it
will improve the speed of our game so
let's go ahead and get started by
developing everything that we just said
here all right so let's start with the
second point that i have mentioned
earlier and that's going to be how to
automatically open the surrounded cells
in case we see the number of zero when
we click on some cell so if we were to
take a look in the left click actions
then you can see that we have a
separation between a cell that is
actually a mine to a cell that is
not a mine so here we can actually check
if the clicked cell
is not mine for sure so this means that
our code is going to be here but we can
also check if the display number is zero
or not and the way that we can do this
is by using the property of surrounded
cells mine's length and we can verify if
that is equal to zero or not so that's
going to look like the following so if
self dot
surrounded cells mine's length is equal
to
zero
then we should do something so if we are
going to enter here then we want to
launch a for loop that will be
responsible to basically display the
mine's length for all the surrounded
cells now we already know that we have a
property that
returns us back a list with all the
surrounded sale objects and that comes
from here so we are going to use this in
that case for sure so that's going to be
like the following so we can say for
cell underscore object in
self.surrounded cells
and we can go ahead and say something
like cell
object
dot show
underscore cell now if you remember we
have a method as well that is called
show cell which we call here so it makes
sense to try to open all the cells that
are surrounded the clicked cell and also
calling the show cell method for them as
well and that's going to work in case of
course if the
mines length is
zero so let's launch the game and see if
we have the expected behavior here so
the expected behavior here is if we
click here and that displays
zero then the game should automatically
open that and that
and that and let's see if we have this
so i'm i'm going to really try to click
here and you can see that we have two so
that's not a good test for us and that's
a mine so we are looking for a zero and
you can see that this works perfectly
you can see that once i clicked on zero
then we got all the numbers that are
surrounded the clicked cell in the first
stage so that's something that is going
to speed the game and going to be
extremely helpful and let's continue
from here alright so now that we have
done this then let's go ahead and see
how we can add some more elements to our
window now we said that we'd like to
display some more information about the
game that we play for example
information like how many sales left in
the game in every situation because
every time you click on a cell then the
amount of sales that left decreases so
let's go ahead and show some text about
that because that's going to be helpful
to see in what situation of game we are
currently at so
the approach of that is going to be
quite equivalent to what we have done
with create button object now if you
remember we used an instance method that
goes ahead and creates a button and then
we go ahead and use this last line here
which is looking like self dot cell
button object equals to btn which will
be the variable that has this button
object stored so we are going to do
pretty much the same thing when it comes
to display the amount of sales that left
in the game we are going to create a
method that will create some text
element in the window and then we are
going to call this method from the main
dot py
file and let's go ahead and start with
this so i'm going to go ahead and say
def
create
cell
count
label now the reason that i'm using
label it is because the name of the
class that are responsible to display
just text without any special
functionality is called label and that's
going to be the class that we're going
to initialize so that is the reason i
can allow myself to call this function i
mean the method the way it is so we are
also going to receive here another
parameter that we can name location and
i'm going to go inside of it and i'm
going to say
label or lbl to make it shorter is equal
to a label now we know that we do not
import this so i'm going to scroll here
and i'm going to say from tk enter
import button and label as well and now
that we have done this then i'm going to
pass in the location argument and then
i'm going to pass in some additional
arguments so this label element accepts
a parameter that is called text like we
have seen with the button and we can go
ahead and say that its text could be a
formatted string like sales
left and let's use a column and then i
can go ahead and use something like the
following i can refer to the amount of
cells that we already know from the
settings so
settings dot
grid size and if i remember correctly
grid size stores six in here because we
just set it to six and so it means that
we have six times six cells so it makes
sense to also use here one more
variable that we can name cell count and
that will be equal to grid size power of
two like that so we can go ahead and as
well as replace this with that one and
that makes totally sense and now i can
go ahead to my
cell dot py file and replace this with
cell count
now things are looking a lot better so
now that we have done this
then let's go ahead and as well as
return the label
object that we have here and now let's
see how we are going to call this from
the main.py file now there is something
that is quite tricky with this method
and that is the fact that
this label
is not something that needs to be
belonged to each of our cells because
that is a general information about the
game so what that means it means that
this cannot be an instance method
because this is just a one-time method
that we want to call throughout the game
we do not want to call this method for
each cell object so that's why
this needs to be a static method and a
static method is a method that is just
for use case of the class and not for
the use case of the instance so that's
why it makes sense to mark it as a
static method now this also means that
we should delete this self because we do
not need to receive the self if we do
not use an instance method so now it's
safe to remove this from here and have a
method like the following now if you
never heard about static methods then
there's actually an episode about static
methods in the python oop series that i
published recently on my channel so be
sure to watch it at least for a couple
of minutes in order to have a better
understanding about static methods all
right so now that we have done this then
let's figure out where we are going to
call this method now if you remember for
the button object we basically used a
statement that looked like the following
so we said that at the beginning
self.cell between object
is equal to num and then we went ahead
and we assigned this
to a button object that is coming from
here so we are going to do the same
thing for the cell count label because
that is going to be helpful when we need
to make use of the cell count label from
the main.py file so
now i can go ahead and create an
attribute that's going to be belong to
the class level not to the instance
level and the reason that i'm doing this
is because the cell count label should
be something that is global should be
something that is not belong
to the instance level so i'm going to go
ahead and say
cell
count label is equal to
none and i can actually add here
underscore object to keep the same
convention like the cell button object
and now that i have done this then i can
change this thing here to something like
cell
dot
cell count label object is equal to lbl
which is the variable name that we use
so that action is quite equivalent to
what we have done previously throughout
the series with the cell button object
and now that we have this then we can go
ahead and use this from the main dot py
like the following so i can go ahead to
here and i can just call this so i'm
going to go ahead and say a comment like
call the
in
label
from the cell class and this should look
like this so we can say cell
dot
create cell count label and the location
for that will be the left frame
now left frame is the frame that is used
to be stored in the left area of our
window now if you remember let me show
you that
it's going to be
right here in that location so if i'm
drawing here or something then this is
the top frame
this is the left frame and this whole
area is the game frame the center frame
that we
use it to play the game so the widget
that i'm talking about should be here
all right so let me clean that and close
the game
great so now we call this method so this
means that i can access the label object
by referring to cell
dot cell
count label object and i can just use
here a
place
in order to place this in somewhere in
the frame and let's start by placing
this in zero x equals to zero and y
equals to zero now if you remember the
numbers are relative to the frame itself
so this should be in the first pixel of
the cell of the left frame excuse me so
if i run the main.py file then you can
see that we have this here now i know
that it's quite small and it needs some
edit to make it bigger and nicer so
that's exactly what we're going to do
now so if we go back to the cell dot py
file and we go inside our static method
which creates the label then we can go
ahead and increase the width and the
height so let's go ahead and use width
equals to
12 and height is equal to 4
exactly like the numbers of our button
and let's also give these attributes
like
bg meaning the background color is equal
to
in black
and we can use the foreground color
parameter as well so we can use fg is
equal to white
and let's see what is going to happen
now so if we were to run the game
then you can see that this is not quite
changing so this means that maybe we
need to increase the font
and parameter here so we can go ahead
and use font is equals to something like
the following so font by default accepts
a tuple so the first argument of this of
this should be the font type and you can
go ahead and play around with your
favorite fonts and the second one should
be the size of the font so i'm going to
start by size of
maybe 48 just see if that's going to be
too much and that is so i'm going to
change this to maybe 30 and that looks
just perfect right now so i'm going to
leave it as it is this means that we can
delete those attributes and continue
from here all right so now that we
understood this then let's see how we
are going to interactively change the
text every time that we click on a cell
and the click cell was actually a cell
and not a mind that finishes the game so
this means that we need to change the
amount of sales left in the text that we
have located in the left frame so this
means that we should be doing this exact
action in the method that we have named
show sell and the reason that we want to
do this here just because that is the
perfect location that
uses some actions when we click on some
cell and that is actually a sale a
regular cell that is not a mine so this
is the exact location that we look to
take some actions when we want to
display regular information about an
open cell so i'm going to use here a
comment that will say replace
the text of
cell
count label
with
the newer account something like that
now in order to test this out then i'm
going to change this to something that
is hard coded just to see that we are
able to do this successfully so let's go
ahead and test this out so at first it
makes sense to check if
sell
dot
count label object is none or not and i
can just do it the way it is if cell dot
cell count label object should be enough
to test if this object is none or is
filled with some information meaning a
label object so if it is then we want to
go ahead and use cell dot
cell count label object and we want to
configure its text to a newer text so in
order to test this then let's go ahead
and use
changed like that and see how it is
going to behave if i'm running that and
clicking on a random location then you
can see that we see a change and that is
perfect so this will be the way that
this is going to work
okay so in that stage let's try to
understand what will be the most
efficient way to store continuously the
sales that left in the game so first
things first we could allow ourselves to
store one more class attribute that we
can name cell count now we know that the
cell count
changes every time
that the show sell
method is being called so what that
means it means that every time that show
sale is being called we could basically
decrease the amount of sales by one so
let me show you how this could look like
so we could go and scroll up and create
here a class attribute that we can name
sell count
which we can also allow ourselves to set
this value to settings dot cell count so
it makes sense to at first have
the value of 36 for example for this
class attribute and we could
continuously decrease this value every
time that the show sell method is being
called so we could go here and use as
the first line something like
sell
dot
cell count
minus equals one and this will be
responsible to decrease the cell count
by one and now that we are doing this
then we are also going to change the
methodology that we store the text in
the label that we have now if you
remember
we used to
store inside the label information about
the left cells meaning the settings dot
cell count but now it makes sense to
change the reference of that to sell dot
cell count like that because that's
going to be
the variable that we are going to
decrease in every time that we click on
a sale so this means that having it like
that is a better idea so now i can allow
myself to copy this and scroll down
and every time that show cell is being
called then i can configure continuously
this text with the following information
so let me delete this from here and
actually jump a line and between those
parentheses i'm going to say text is
equal to exactly the same thing and this
needs to be configured every time a cell
is being clicked because we need to
so-called refresh the information that
is displayed in that label so now that
we have done this then it is about time
to test if that is going to work
all right so if we
launch our main.py file then let's see
what is going to happen so
if we click here then you can see that
the amount here has been decreased now
it could have been great if we will hit
a cell that has zero surrounded minds to
see if that is going to work properly as
well so if we click here you can see
that this yet works great and this is 34
32 and 33 excuse me and you can see
that here we have a mismatch and that's
happening
because it thinks that it should also
decrease the amounts for the
mines that are here as well now
again let me show you what happened here
just right now so at first we clicked
here
here and then here right and we saw a
perfect behavior of 33 in there but now
we try to click here
but the game thinks that those cells
should be
opened as well and that's why
not only that it decreased to 32 it also
decreased by five because it decreased
the amount for this and that
and this and that
and
this and that right so it's important to
handle this situation with something
that we can do just right now because
that is a bug in our game
so let's clean here and go ahead and see
how we can handle this
so the way that we can handle this is by
setting up an attribute that is going to
be belong to each cell that we can name
something like is underscore opened now
is underscore opened is going to be a
boolean type of variable that we can set
by default to false and every time that
the show cell
is called based on that sale object we
can convert this boolean variable into
true and that will mark this cell as
being opened and in that case we can
conditional our program to only
decrease the cell count if the cell is
not opened yet so let's go ahead and
design such functionality so i'm going
to scroll up and i'm going to say here
something like the following i'm going
to say self dot is underscore opened and
i'm going to set this to false because
in the beginning of the game it makes
sense to say that
each cell is not opened yet and now that
we have done this then every time that
we use the method of show cell then
right after we finish all of our
functions then we can go ahead and say
something like self dot is
opened excuse me is equal to
true like that and let me use a comment
here that will say
mark the cell as opened
use it
as the last line of this method
something like the following should be
enough to explain why we are doing this
right here so now we can allow ourselves
to do something like the following we
can say if
self dot is opened and we actually want
to test if that is not opened so this
means that i'm going to add here
not so this is going to check if the
cell is not opened yet and if that is
the case then i want to indent
everything inside this conditional
because the only case that i want to
execute this
and this and as well as those lines is
in the case if the cell is not opened
yet so that is perfectly making sense to
use the code the way that we use it just
right now so now that we have done all
of this then let's test now if our game
is going to behave as expected
so i'm going to execute this main dot py
file again and i'm going to try to
click on that one and that is a mine so
it makes sense that the sales left is
not decreasing because we should be
finishing the game in that case but we
did not want to do that because it will
interrupt our development process so
let's actually try to execute our game
one more time
and try to play the game like it needs
to be played so you can see that now we
see two so let's try to not click here
to not face with a mine
try to click here so this is 34 still
works perfect 33
and that's a mine so let's give it one
more try
if we click here okay perfect result
because you can see that we have now now
nine cells opened and this is decreased
by nine so let's test if that is going
to continue working great so if we click
on those three then those are pretty
safe because we have a zero here so 26
25 24 and you can see that this works
really perfect because once we click in
here it only decreased by two and those
two
were for this one and for
that one so now we have a great game
going on without any bugs and we handled
a lot of things that could lead to
trouble in the future okay so let's show
an example of what we want to do in that
episode so if we run our game
and we start to play a bit and for
example we click here we know that we
have three minds
around there but in order to start
figuring out what could be the minds i
mean the cells that you should not click
on then you need some utility that will
say to yourself that you should not
click on that in the future so it could
have been nicer if we could develop a
future that will color the cell in a
different color so we can differentiate
between the cells that we mark as
mine candidates and that's exactly what
we are going to design in that episode
so the way that this feature is going to
work is by using the right click of our
mouse button so if we are going to click
right click on a cell then it is going
to color it with a color like orange
maybe some color that will be a good
color to differentiate between a mind
candidate to an actual mind that
basically leads us to lose the game so
it's basically going to be something
that will responsible to
color the cell with the given color now
say that we clicked on some location
that we marked as mine candidate we also
like to develop the opposite action
which is going to be unmark the cell as
a mine candidate so those are both of
the functionalities that we are going to
work just right now so let's go ahead
and get started okay so the approach of
doing something like this it is going to
be pretty much similar to what we have
done with the ease open the attribute we
could first start with creating a new
attribute to each of our cell objects
that will go something like self dot is
mine candidate something like that and
this value could be false for each of
our cells at first the reason that this
could happen is because at first we
never mark ourselves as mind candidates
we just start with a new blank game so
now that we have such an attribute it
makes sense to go ahead and take some
actions when we right click on a cell
and if you remember we already have a
method that is called right click
actions and we could find this just by
scrolling down a bit because this should
be right here okay there it is so here's
the exact location that i could allow
myself to do something when we right
click on a cell and one of the things
that i can do is to change the attribute
from
false to true so i can go ahead and say
if
not self. is
my candidate so i'm checking if this
sale is
already not a mine candidate then i can
go ahead and do some things now one of
the first things that i want to do is to
change the background color of the cell
so it is going to visually mark it as a
mind candidate so it will be self dot
cell btn object dot configure
and we are going to call this method and
i'm just going to pass in here bg
background color equals to orange and
now that i have done this i can also
allow myself to change from false to
true so i can say self dot is underscore
mind candidate
equals to
true like the following so now let's go
ahead and test if that is going to work
for us so i'm going to execute our game
and i'm just going to right click on a
cell and you can see that this works
perfectly now we said that we'd also
like to design
the opposite action which is just what
we are going to do now and before we do
that i want you to notice something
important in here
you'll see that the cells left is not
decreased and that is good because we
did not open this cell right so that's
an important behavior that we want to
keep so it doesn't matter how many
times we are going to click right click
it's good that the sales left value is
not decreasing here so that's something
that i wanted to show up all right so
now that we have this then we should
also design the opposite action by only
saying here else so now we are doing
something if
this cell is already a mind candidate
now the next time that we are going to
right click on a cell and we know that
the cell is mine candidate then we just
want to do the opposite action so the
opposite action will be to configure the
color
to the original color so it will be self
dot cell btn object dot configure we're
gonna call this method now this might be
confusing here but there is a specific
value for the background color that you
should specify that is already the
default color for each of the
hinter elements that you are creating
and that is called system
button
face and that is just the color that you
see in the beginning right the kind of
gray color so that's the reason that i
am writing this thing as the value of
the bg
and then the next thing that i'm going
to do is obviously changing this to
false so i'm going to say self dot is my
candidate
is equal to
false like that and that's probably
going to work without any surprises so
if i'm right clicking
one time two times three times then now
let's try to undo our action so i'm
going to again right click here and
again here and as well as here you can
see that this works so that's a great
start for having some mind candidates
going on now let's also try to play the
game with that right see if we did
something bad to rest of our game so
that's a good test for us
so i'm going to left click basically
open some cells and you can see that
this works i can continue on clicking
here here and there
and that's working great now let's say
that i think that this is a mine here so
i'm just going to right click
continue opening that
and as well as that one now this is
actually a mine because for example if
we take a look at this cell right you
can see that it's supposed to have one
mine in here here here here or there so
that's the mind for sure so that's good
future now that we can mark this as a
mind candidate so we know that we should
never click on that with the left mouse
click now i just wanted to remind
something that could lead you to some
problems using this mine candidate
feature i said earlier in this series
that if you use button dash 3 like i did
in here then you might have some
problems because in some mouse
configurations it expects for button
dash too but since i have the mouse
wheel in my mouse then it should be
button dash 3 for myself so if you
notice that things are not working for
you pretty much as expected then try to
use other combinations of numbers like 2
or even 4 just try to use something that
is not 3 and i want to hope that it will
work for you alright so now that we have
done this then let's go ahead and design
some final things that we want in order
to have the complete game now we already
know that we pretty much not finish the
game when we
actually click on a mine so i'm going to
do something that will immediately warn
a message that we lost the game if we
click on a mine now in order to do this
i'm going to assume that you are working
on a windows machine but the way that
you should quit a game with an exception
is really up to you i'm just going to
show one example but there are tons of
other options that you can go ahead with
it and of course since i'm using a
windows machine then this example might
be more fit for windows environments
okay so the first thing that i'm going
to do here is import some library that
will be responsible to throw a general
message about how we lost the game or
something like that so in order to do
that i like the library that is called
see types and that's just a library that
can help you to throw generic messages
warnings arrows any kind of things that
you want to come up with them so now
that we have this
then i'm going to use this library and
basically throw a message if we open a
mine now if you remember
we have a method that is called show
mine and you see that we already have a
comment that says a logic to interrupt
the game and display a message that
player lost so here is the exact
location that we want to write such a
functionality and that's what i'm about
to do right now so if we delete this now
i'm going to go ahead and just write a
generic message so we are going to use
this c types library and then i'm going
to pick up the
win
dll
sub library and then i'm going to use
the user 32
and then i'm going to say message
box w like that now this is just a
generic message box that i'm going to
throw out all right so i'm going to pass
in here several arguments and once we
see the result then i will explain why i
did that okay so i will start by saying
zero and then i will say you clicked on
a mine and i will pass in one more
string that will look like game over and
then i will again pass in the argument
of zero now before we test this i want
to change the ordering in here so first
we'd like to
change the configuration of this
background color to red and then we'd
like to throw a message right so now
let's go ahead and play the game and
intentionally click on a mine right so
let's try to click somewhere here okay
so you can see that we receive a general
message box now you can see if we show
this side by side
like
the following then you can see that at
first
where is the message box here it is
so you can see that the first string was
responsible to the body of our message
box because we see the you clicked on a
mine in its body and you can see that
the second text was responsible to show
the title now those numbers here and
here are responsible to deliver you
specific kinds of message boxes now the
fact that i have zero here is
responsible to give me only one option
of a button to click and that will be
okay
i think if i was to change this to
something like 2 then i would receive
the options of yes
no and cancel something in that kind so
i'm going to re-run our game and again
i'm going to lose it
okay so you can see that i was quite
right it is abort retry and ignore and
you can try to play around with
different numbers and you will see
different results but for myself i only
want to receive okay just confirm it and
continue with rest of the actions that i
want to do and i'm going to refer you to
a link which will explain you what
number is responsible for what so if you
want to take further actions with this
message box be sure to check the link in
the description all right so i'm going
to press somewhere just turn it back to
zero
and maximize our python and continue
from here all right so right after we
have this message box and right after we
clicked okay then we should just
terminate the game we should exit it now
you have all the options what you'd like
to do whenever you click ok you can also
decide that you would like to develop a
functionality to restart the game i'm
just going to exit it in the way that
you exit a python process that is
running is by cys.exit
like that now cys is a library that you
should import so i'm going to
scroll up and say
import cys and let's see if everything
together is going to
work perfectly for us so i'm going to
run the game
and let's try to again lose it
intentionally okay so you clicked on a
mine the second that i press ok it
should be terminated and that's exactly
what is happening so that's a perfect
thing and now we have a complete game
that we can try to play we can try to
win it and we might also lose it
sometimes and we just need to play again
until we win the minesweeper game
alright so now that we have done this
then there are several things that we
also want to finish out before we have
the complete game without any bugs and
without any problems so now if we try to
play the game and let's assume that we
have some minds that are candidates for
a mind so let's just randomly click here
and then let's assume that i mark this
as a mind candidate although it doesn't
make sense and right after that i left
click on that
right like the following then you can
see that now we have a bit of problem
because we might also expect to have the
original background color again so what
we need to do we need to also specify in
case we left click on a cell and we open
it we also want to be configuring the
background color to the original system
button face color that we used so that's
exactly what we should do now in order
to not face with a situation like the
following where we have an open cell but
we also have this cell as being shown
like a mind candidate which is pretty
funny and
we need to handle that
so we should go
to our open cell method or show cell
here it is and we should be doing the
exact same action of changing the
background color to system bottom face
right here right so we can
go ahead and say here something like
if
this was a mine candidate
then for safety
we should
configure the background color to system
button phase something like that so we
can really understand in the future why
we have done this here as well and i'm
just going to do the same thing like we
have done previously so it's going to be
self dot cell btn object dot configure
and that's going to be bg equals to
system
button
face
like that and let's go ahead and check
if this is going to fix the bug for us
so i'm going to click here
mind candidate and then left click so
this looks great this looks like it
works so we can continue to do the next
things that we want to do right now
all right so now we might think that we
have the perfect game without any bugs
but let me tell you that we still have
some problems that we could figure out
in order to have the perfect game and
the perfect code for the game so if we
try to
launch our game then let's
try to click on some places here like
here and as well as there alright so
works great but yet let me tell you that
if we click with our left click on some
cell
then this still is going to call the
left click actions method which that
might be something that we want to avoid
because there is no reason to call any
method if we already opened a cell and
it might seem like it doesn't do
anything to you because the sales left
amount is not decreasing but actually
something is happening in the background
okay let me prove you by also try to
click with my right mouse click so
if we right click now then you can see
that i can still mark those as mine
candidates which is not good so the way
that we want to handle this is by
canceling the events
for the buttons i mean the cells
that already have been opened so the way
that we can do this is use the opposite
action of the method that was
responsible to assign the event so we
assigned some events in the beginning of
this entire series now if cell has been
opened we want to cancel those events so
let's go ahead and see how we can
do that one so you can see
that
here
we assign events for
left click and for right click so
if we open a cell then we should do the
opposite action and let me tell you that
tkinter has a method that is called
unbind meaning cancel all the events
that are assigned to that specific
button right so that's exactly what
we're going to do just right now so i'm
going to
go to our left click actions
and i'm going to execute here some lines
that will be responsible to cancel all
the events on the clicked cell so i'm
going to say cancel
left and right click events
if cell
is already opened and that is safe to do
that because in case we left click on a
cell then we open a cell and if we lose
the game then the game just exits so it
makes sense to right here this
functionality so it's going to look like
self dot cell btn object dot on bind and
we're gonna need to call this twice so
we are going to unbind the events for
button dash one so i'm going to just
copy this string
and
paste this in
here and i'm going to do the same for
button dash 3
and that should be responsible to cancel
all the events now let's check if that's
going to work so i'm going to launch the
game
and click somewhere and now i'm going to
try to
right click on that you can see nothing
happens and that's exactly what we want
let's also test with some other location
like here
here and
here maybe so now i will try to left
click you can see nothing really happens
if i right click and again nothing
really happens but if i right click here
then something's supposed to happen so
that's exactly what we want
we want to cancel the events for the
sales that are already opened
all right so there's going to be one
final thing that we want to do before we
can play the game from the beginning to
the end now the case that we win a game
is in case that we have
the amount of sales being equal to
amount of mines
let me repeat that now let's say that in
this case we have nine mines in our game
right because if you remember from
settings.py we know that mines count is
cell count divided by four now in our
case it is six power of two which is 36
divided by 4 is 9. so whenever we have 9
cells left in the game but we still able
to play the game then here's the exact
case
that we can raise a message that we won
the game right
congratulations something in that kind
so that's exactly the last thing that we
want to do just right now all right so
let's go ahead and try to design this i
will go to cell.py file and it makes
sense to raise a message like
congratulations
if on
show sell
we have the expected match right where
sales count is equal to the mines count
so i can just go under the self dot show
cell and i can say something like
if mines count
is equal to
the sales left count
player one something like that and let's
write this right so i'm going to say if
sell
dot cell count if you remember this was
a class attribute
is equal to settings
dot
minds count
then i'm just going to copy the line
that was responsible to show a message
and i'm only going to change the text
inside of that
so let's find this message
it should be in the show mine
method so i'm going to just ctrl f that
and you can see that
here it is so i'm just going to copy
that
and paste this in
right here and i'm only going to change
the arguments so i'm going to say
game over
congratulations
you
want the game something like that
alright so now that we have this
let's play our game from the beginning
to the end
alright so before we go ahead and try
the game from the beginning to end we
said that we'd like to have a title for
the game and that's something that we
should do earlier so let me do that
quickly let's do this together by
writing game underscore title is equal
to a label we said that for creating
pure text it is a great idea to use the
label class of tk inter library and we
want to position this in the top frame
we want the background color being black
and the foreground color meaning the
text color
to be
white now we'd also like to pass in here
text equals to mine sweeper
minesweeper game
and the font should be a tuple
and the first argument of the tuple
should be the font type so you can play
around with any font type you'd like to
i will just leave it an empty string and
i will say size is equal to 48 like that
and now that i have this then i'm also
going to say game title dot place
and let's use 25 percent of the width
size of the top frame
we have this utils dot width prct
which receives the amount of percentage
to use from the x axis and now that i
have this then i'm going to go out from
these parenthesis and i'm going to say y
is equal to
0 and then i'm just going to launch the
game and you can see that it looks great
alright so speaking about playing the
game let's try to figure out how we can
win that game so just going to play it
and guess where the mines are located
alright so we have my one mind
surrounded here
and we clicked on a mine
it might take a few times until we win
it but let's hope for the best okay so
that's a mine as well
um that was a mine
if we click here on the middle so we
have three here so it's quite dangerous
to try to figure out
where the mines are located okay so we
have some zeros and that's the best
practice probably to go with okay so you
can see
that
around this one around this one here we
have one mine so say that we guess that
we have a mine here then we are allowed
to click there okay so we guessed right
and so you can see that here we have a
one and there is already a mine here so
we can click
here for sure
all right so now we need to figure out
where rest of the mines
so here
we have three minds surrounded and as
well as here so i'm going to assume that
we have a mind here for sure
and as well as
here so this means that we don't have a
mine here and we lost the game so let's
give it one more try maybe you can win
it let me know in the comment section if
you can win this minesweeper game it is
quite important and let's give it a last
try and promise i'm not going to try
anymore because the video is just going
to be too long all right so if we click
here
so we have one mine
around here so i'm not going to guess
that okay so some zeros zeros are great
for us
and
i'm going to guess that here we have a
mind so here we don't have a mind all
right nice guess so now it means that i
can click here here here
here and there and also here so you can
see that now looking at this one you can
see that there is a mine here so i'm
also allowed to click there
also here and also here all right so now
that we have this we can also try to
click here because we have a one there
okay so now we know that we have one
mine
around this one so that's a mine for
sure and this means that if we look in
this number then we can also click here
here and
here all right so looking at this one
we can click here because that's a mine
for sure
so now we can look on this one
that's a mine
that we marked as a mine candidate so we
can click here
all right so now it is getting
complicated
and
if we guess that here we have a mine
then we can left click here all right
great guess we can continue playing so
you can see that looking at this three
this and that are mines absolutely right
so we already found six so three more to
go it's quite exciting
and all right so i think i don't have
anything left to guess
so i need to go here up top
and i'm going to think that
that's a mine so if i left click here oh
my god all right so i can leave you the
all the time in the world to try to
figure out and play the game and win it
and i think that's pretty much it about
this series
now as usual if you enjoyed this entire
course please be sure to hit the like
button and that's it so i hope you all
enjoyed and see you on my next series